Now, just as on a CPU, there are different levels of optimization for the GPU.
There's picking good algorithms in the first place.
There's some basic principles for writing efficient code.
There's architecture-specific detailed optimizations,
and there's sort of bit twiddling micro-optimization at the instructions level.
So, let's use a quiz to explore a few CPU examples. There's the use of vector registers such as SSE and AVX.
There's the use of something like mergesort which runs an order n log n time versus insertion sort
which runs an order n squared time. Next is writing cache-aware code,
meaning write code that is likely to make efficient use of the cache.
So an example would be it's generally faster to traverse across the rows of a large 2D array than down the columns,
assuming that array is laid out in row order. You'll get better cache performance in that case.
Or you can do explicit cache blocking, for example,
for the L1 cache and a CPU core.
Or finally, you could approximate the inverse square root of a floating point number
by shifting it right one bit and subtracting it from the integer 0x5f3759df.